Speaker 1: We're continuing to learn more
from this forthcoming book by Carol Leonnig
and Philip Rucker from The Washington Post.
And it seems like it's almost every day we
get something new from this book.
But the latest one is based on excerpts that
now point out that Donald Trump talked to
Carol Leonnig and Philip Rucker.
So this is actually super, super interesting.
Trump granted the authors of this new book.
An hours long interview, the book is called
I Alone Can Fix It now, you might be wondering
why exactly would he do that?
And they actually talk about this in this
Vanity Fair piece where they point out Donald
Trump previously turned down speaking to them
for a prior book.
This time he wanted to talk to them and they
actually say Trump had invited us to Mar a
Lago.
Let me make sure we have this on screen.
Trump It invited us to Mar a Lago to interview
him for this book.
He had declined an interview for our first
book about his presidency and when a very
stable genius was published in January of
twenty twenty, attacked us personally and
branded our reporting a work of fiction.
But Trump was quick to agree to our request.
This time he sought to curate history.
Listen to this.
As we sat for the interview, the president's
former president's press secretary presented
us with with copies of a bound volume One
Thousand Accomplishments of President Donald
J. Trump.
Highlights of the first term on the back cover
is the American flag, the presidential seal
and Trump's thick, jagged signature.
The book totals ninety two pages and is organized
with chapters dedicated to the economy, tax
cuts, deregulation, trade and so on.
Trump walked into the room flanked by plain
clothed Secret Service, a much smaller, detailed
and he once had.
He wore his dark suit and tie, his bronzed
makeup, whatever.
OK, here is the relevant section that I want
to show you, which goes to Trump's latest,
his biggest regret.
This is absolutely fascinating and very, very
scary.
Over the years, Trump rarely has expressed
misgivings, but he regrets his response to
protests last summer in Minneapolis, Portland,
Seattle and other cities.
Now, you might hear that and say, oh, maybe
he regrets threatening to send in military.
Maybe he regrets the despicable things he
said about protesters are defending the police
brutality.
No, no, no, no, no.
I think if I had to do it again, I would have
brought in the military immediately.
He said.
What if he had another opportunity?
He would have more quickly scaled up the violence
and the repression of the protesters by the
military.
Remember when he was thinking about this,
that I and others said, OK, so hold on a second.
You have protests triggered by excessive use
of force by law enforcement against George
Floyd that that was the catalyst for these
protests.
Trump's natural instinct is to send in military
to shut down the protests, which were overwhelmingly
peaceful.
That is truly the tendency, the knee jerk
reaction of an authoritarian.
It's a horrible thing.
Now, ultimately, it didn't end up going down
that way and that's a very good thing and
get having a chance to do it over again, Trump
says.
I wish I had sent in the military more quickly.
Trump had they go on to say Trump had no such
second thoughts about his handling of the
pandemic.
He said he had been very tough in protecting
the country by restricting travel first from
China, then Europe.
He said he did so against the wishes of his
top medical advisers.
In fact, most of them agreed with the restrictions
before he made the decision.
That's true, according to participants in
the discussions and their contemporaneous
notes.
But he correctly said he pushed scientists
at the FDA at a level that they have never
been pushed before to get vaccines approved
in record time.
Trump may have been pushing people, but there
is no reason to believe, based on everything
we know, that Trump had anything to do with
these vaccines being approved any quicker
than they would have been without him.
This is just a delusion.
One last bit of flavor quote, I think we did
a great job on covid and it hasn't been recognized,
Trump said, noting other countries saw spikes
in covid infections in the months after he
left office.
The cupboards were bare.
We didn't have gowns.
We didn't have masks.
We didn't have ventilators.
We didn't have anything.
We brought in plane loads.
We did a great job.
When we asked Trump why, he encouraged people
to believe things that weren't true or to
distrust science and the media, he delighted
in talking about the scientific smarts in
his family's genes.
Can you imagine?
First of all, I'm a big person.
Do you know this?
My uncle, Dr. John Trump, I think he was at
the Massachusetts Institute of Technology
longer than any other professor.
Totally brilliant man.
He had numerous degrees.
So that's in the genes.
I always go with that stuff, but it's a little
bit in the genes.
And Dr. John Trump was a great guy.
No, I'm a big believer in science.
If I wasn't, you wouldn't have a vaccine.
It depends.
Are you talking about disinformation or are
you talking about lies?
There's a more beautiful word called disinformation.
So Trump seems to be saying he didn't lie,
but he did spread disinformation, which I
don't know that it actually makes it any better,
horrifying and delusional.
And what's very interesting is, as they point
out, Trump never apologizes for anything.
Trump doesn't have regrets, never.
Here you finally get him to, I guess, reflect
and say there is something I wish I would
have done differently.
I wish I would have send in troops to repress
protests about police brutality more quickly.
Just absolutely horrifying and dystopian in
absolutely every sense of the word